une production du studio sfr bienvenue
aux sans filtre le podcast on parle de
ce qu'on veut nous inviter dati site
super h 40 ans avec moi de dôme plantes
cette semaine là sans filtre encore une
fois présenté par terriens terriens cpa
terrain terriens c'est un bureau de
comptable ça fait plus de 25 ans qui
sont ouverts ils se sont spécialisés
dans les pme donc les petites et
moyennes entreprises de 1 à 100 employés
qui oeuvrent dans des domaines de
l'avenir donc le jeu vidéo
l'informatique la biotechnologie même un
studio de podcasts comme le nôtre on y
est on se fait aider par les gens chez
terrain terriens qui au contraire de
certaines grandes firmes qui ont
beaucoup beaucoup de clients qui traite
les clients comme des numéros
le contact est extrêmement humain on
peut en témoigner sont vraiment faim
sérieux en plus d'être d'être vraiment
bons sont vraiment faim oui exactement
donc si vous voulez dans le fonds offre
un service clé en main que ce soit pour
votre tenue de livres les états
financiers les rapports d'impôt demande
des crédits d'impôts ou une en
choisissant parmi tout seul de il offre
toutes les possibilités
puis en utilisant le code sans filtre
lorsque vous allez prendre votre premier
rendez vous ils vont vous offrir 50 %
sur votre première année financière fait
que ça c'est de l'argent vous allez
pouvoir prendre et investir dans votre
compagnie comme nous on le fait
présentement avec le studio
donc merci la gagne était un terrien bon
encore une fois commandité le sans
filtre podcast sinon c'est très bien
leur sujet datant au roi quiconque
connaît maintenant il fait les musées
qui sont chanteurs mes soucis un ex
hockeyeur c'est le fils d'un des plus
grands joueurs de hockey je pense de
l'histoire patrick roy mais un homme qui
qui dépasse en fait de loin l'image ou
peut-être la préconception part de lui
vraiment ça a été un super beau podcast
par balles raconte en fait c'est c'est
lui qui nous a écrit parce qu'ils
voulaient participer au bas de casse
c'est pire en général on essaie de bien
choisir notre rugby
photo cc influencé par les gens qui
disent moi moi moi j'ai participé mais
du roi écrit parfaitement
recall j'entends roi vraiment pis ça a
été encore 100 fois plus cool que
j'aurais pensé que ça aurait pu l'être 1
go qui ont terminé fait de démarches de
recherche de soi de développement
personnel qui est parti en voyage avec
son chien dans une vanne qui s'est
vraiment trouvé j'ai l'impression qui
est arrivé avec une sagesse puis avec
vraiment maturité incroyable on a parlé
de peine afin d'en parler de sexualité
on a parlé de drogues hallucinogènes de
parler de musique super belle
conversation bellum belles rencontres
ouais on en a sorti entre que moi j'en
ai sorti grandi de ce podcast lui
surtout par rapport à la conception
qu'on peut avoir de la société dans
lequel on évolue le soir une
conversation puis je les réécoute
eyharts en fait c'est drôle on tombe
rapidement dans le sujet le haut et un
petit panier âgées auxerre 1-1
extrêmement une belle découverte
sinon depuis mois on fait des podcasts
vip avec du monde de notre entourage
donc ces mêmes principes que le sans
filtre mais c'est avec du monde un petit
peu moins connus du grand public
c'est disponible sur notre page
piquionne donc les sans filtre vip sinon
abonnez-vous à gauche a laissé des
commentaires on aime vous lire
participer aux conversations partait je
sais que vos amis puis sinon bon pas de
4,7
bonne écoute
rouyère jo merci dernière pour savoir
je faisais j'ai fait un genre de tri
dans mes abonnés instagram je faisais
georges partiellement mais mon fils puis
j'ai ce que cette personne me procure du
positif
quand je tombe ce ton profil se dit
astiquer le fun à suivre texte parce que
moi j'ai un respect énorme pour ceux qui
aiment qu'ils font un genre de de
phoques la programmation des caisses que
je supposais à être qu'est ce que la
société voudrait que choix
c'est quoi le moule dans lequel font
embarquer mais toi même tu représentes
la personne qui fait non arrêtez ça
existe pas un moule comme seuls les
gueux ya un veilleur many of the road ce
problème comme ça puis cech j'imagine
sachant d'où tu viens ça change ton
passé kyi de farce heures mais j'ai le
plus grand respect du monde la façon
avec laquelle d'abord de la route semble
aborder du moins à travers 13 ou si
c'est le prix beaucoup de brandon
énormément temps je pense que je t'ai 1
sont vos ordres et bac quand j'ai
commencé dans l'arc et cdt encore dry tu
fais ce que le coach de 10,3 à l'école
après ça ce qui arrive je suis
entraîneur dans la musique en compagnie
de disques presse un autre compagnie de
disques un autre compagnie de disques un
autre disque et là j'ai 30 ans il ça
fait ça fait trois ans maintenant que
j'ai décidé que j'allais faire les
choses pour moi et j'ai tranquillement
j'avais plus de succès à chaque année
j'avais plus de succès plus d'argent
plus de succès dans la loi 104 matches
ça me montrer que dans le fond
happiness ouï fm c'est toi qui décide
que j'avais plus de temps peut-être tard
et étalement des dettes et qui tous à
jamais salie c'est l'erreur que j'ai
faite pendant sa jeunesse mais c'est ce
que je rattrape
je rate raji rattraper un crissement
taux était dans l'oeil de mon longtemps
le fils de député net était le fils des
piles fc kidjo watts puis je pense que
les gens savent pas pantoute
on sait ce qui colle quand même les gens
ont encore la chance de me découvrir
moi j'en ai aucune idée chikhi si tu
fais ça brouillard je faisais un shoot à
montréal puis un marquage ce et toiles
piste de patrie mais c'est correct c'est
quand même elle des gens on dirait que
sont vraiment stockées là tu sais
qu'avec mon parent a fait des grandes
grandes choses
montréal le monde puis c'est je suis
fier de lui donc je suppose pas comment
le nom est anna barnak mais c'est pas
sûr est ce que je veux avec jeanne
atteint c'est normal sa propre personne
tyson dans le sport ça m'encourage à ne
pas trop écouter écouter les autres afin
de traiter rapidement la même dynamique
dans celle de la société ou complète
mois et étaient rapidement la dent à
musique c'est tellement une dynamique
s'était plus festif est ce plutôt kaki
qu'est ce que je veux faire ma première
fois moi j'ai signé avec richard samson
moi c'était comme mon premier manager
qui lui était quand même qui fait fait
des affaires
pas de stress écrit des tonnes puis on
va t'il vraiment ce développement après
ça avec échasses est devenu plus tard
c'est devenu comme il le faut que tu te
sers le kid si on va faire sa sauce au
sopi puis éventuellement magie on a
comme le top de ce que j'aurais pu faire
donc j'ai signé avec avec paul people et
à la maman faste un encadrement puis
qu'on en fait pas faire grand chose mais
ça tout le temps été des gens qui ont
comme je sais pas lyon vous lui même
afin qu ils ont voulu passer c'est
correct et on voulait de mentor puis à
la fin si lyon ils ont mis ce que
voulait être moi et non ce que moi je
voulais et ils veulent pas mal faire les
jeunes c'est juste qu'ils veulent le
mieux pour toi fais kuito l'impression
d'être pogny de faire les choses pour
les autres de t'habiller d'une façon de
taper par celui d'établissement et être
jamais l'impression d'un toit moi-même
d'un ton album après album après album
j'écoute mes méthodes crise ne sais pas
- photo pour la mort semble peu au pyla
ben j'ai acheté le vert puis le tout a
commencé
cela commence et je participe ma femme
clic déclic et j'ai commencé à écrire
pour moi j'ai mes pay as you d'abord
j'ai rencontré deux groupes grunge et
j'ai commencé à écrire avec eux puis
fait que je vais ce bord de l'autoroute
ce piscine maraka avec toutes les sans
abri 25 mai j'étais là j'écrivais les
toons rend le jour le soir j'allais au
studio j'allais rentrer le style
10 12 ans j'ai fait c'est n'ont pas
encore vu le jour le 29 juillet au 7
janvier
je travaille complètement indépendant
cette fois ci mon argent ma vision
ça fait du bien d'être c'est vraiment
différent de ce que tu as fait
absolument motive chaque année on évolue
comme humain chacun gagne chaque moment
convient de quad intense on évolue fait
que c'est mon évolution jeu rang duquel
par daho puis en vérité je l'écrive le
un an cet album là puis le jeu tant rien
écrire quelque chose de combiner encore
différent c'est ça on est toujours à
l'aria str lalem notre démarche c'est
quand ça sort on est des jeunes sont
rendus alors là c'est absolument cesser
la 6c lendemain s'est classé lens et
offre un ton et qu'il faut tout ça en
ligne c'est complexe
mon amusé carey est ce que tu te mets de
la pression ça commence à être
sud-soudan christ du shodan dit je te
mentir et que je m'en crisse moi mais
c'est ce qu'on s'en fait de la musique
on le fait je mens je le fais pour moi
mais en fait vraiment ça pour ça mais si
je capable d'aller chez dédé du monde
puis de faire triper du monde c'est le
fan fait triper du mexique
si tu te retournes dans le shop et vous
ça m'est arrivé une coupe deux fois dans
ma ville et horton puis finalement il
écoute ta toune au bord dé voir et des
voix chante et atsé le français tu te
l'impression de faire partie des gens
pis cette bio le faux fuyant sûrement
aujourd'hui ça ça n'a rien à voir le
style parce que je vois même pas me
touré puis j'imagine que tout est propre
tout le monde soit en show des capotes
guitare garantie gens ont la larme à
l'oeil tu dois vraiment vu quelque chose
mais l'autre jour j'ai fait des choses
et puis on joue mnsd cover puis j'ai
quand même eu un déclic une fois le
monde l'avait tellement fun un moment
donné je sais tellement comme une bulle
de bonheur
ça m'a rendu ému mine j'ai fait gagner
genre vraiment un 10 minutes le fait que
nous sommes vraiment inquiets ce moment
là je fais ce que je pouvais faire un
nice m'a dit moi j'ai eu ce sentiment là
une coupe devant dans ma vie mais elle
qui m'a frappé de plus au festival d'été
de québec
lot 2 je voudrais plus bas que je suis
bon esprit
des croyants petit à petit j'ai
peut-être jamais avoir cette chance là
de tout fait seul d'été de québec où ou
de juin n'a vendu autant de personnes je
les ai tellement ça vous justement à
mende le quand j'ai chanté good thing
big thing pour moi écoutez l'album de
mars avec la sa dépression puis quand
j'ai vu tout le monde chantait la toune
ça me fait c'est à 60 70 mille personnes
qui chantent font que kingdom puisque
québec
c'est pour ça qu'ils jouaient les jeux
les plaines c'est le rêve c'est
incroyable ça existe
exact dans mouche j'ai commencé chez
nous n'ont pas mam avait acheté un drame
pénitents op tige jamais j'aurais pensé
de faire les plaines d'abraham infecte
ici même dessiné pour la musique harbour
c'était au début c'est sur ce texte est
off parce que je le faisais pour moi
main vraiment au début le salon salle a
commencé parce que j'aimais la musique
et à quel âge
à quel âge que tu savais où d'y penser
vouloir ou leur fassent se joue encore
au hockey que je voulais faire
professionnellement pour le plaisir
professionnels et valence où ce taux que
l'enquêteur moins que je me suis dit
quand tu cherchais quelque chose - ben
moi mais j'aurais pu continuer mais
j'aurais pas été loin j'aurai joué
peut-être isco ce jet en europe par une
couple d'années formé
mais à mon panneau donne tout son talent
mais la donne et 1,5 pour ça moi ça
aurait fait la job mais le chat ne
citons pas non mais mon gant par mon
gars appasamy siens gras même si la
bagarre a été michel jazz très bon il ya
été dans le groupe des mégatonnes dans
les années si je prends les
mathématiques 65 ans mais il joue encore
aujourd'hui mais je le connais pas
beaucoup
on se ressemble beaucoup aux normes ce
n'est pas vraiment une relation là mais
l'ayant on se voit on parle de musique
c'est l'fun signalons le ponde moi
c'était des faux les parents font le
pont pour d'une génération à une autre
sans trop de succès entre les entrées
génération mettons une génération qui
fait le pont entre la première et la
troisième est honteuse et pour qui pour
elle pour la déconnexion et non je pense
qu'une zone c'est plus une affaire de
famille en fait tu dis de la marne va
falloir puis dans le fond oui tu as
raison on a forcé sa sourde saout est
moins grave à la descente hausse dopée
rock je ne savais même pas leurs mains
quand tu fais ce move l'heure de dire je
continue parce que tout le monde
s'attend que je continue puis je fais ce
que je veux réellement fort combien de
temps parce que ces années là on dirait
kleynhoff au sens où ça va être
difficile d'être pris au sérieux dans ce
milieu là bah oui même encore
aujourd'hui
ouais tu le sont encore aujourd'hui
absolument syncope moi j'ai peut-être
que c'est juste parce que je sais pas
quel âge a brossé une question ouais ça
vous tue pendant ce raid soutenir voire
un shojo ouais ouais ouais moi très
probablement moi mais c'est peut-être
parce que je pense que je ne suis pas la
même façon que je te suis maintenant ok
ouais mais la plupart des gens si
c'était plus tu es sorti en même temps
que c'était une joie de son fils a fait
un album de musique c'est le risque à
dresde ville natale bâle - ouais
bon moi mais bon c'est un trip qui se
bat mais tout le monde me comparer à lui
ouvertement grillades mois puis je me
rappelle mes premiers shows j'avais du
monde qui menaçait de l'ambiance à
sanmen je mets mon bleu se bat avec
moins j'avais j'avais deux 2 passes et
c'était quelque chose au début de ma
carrière c'est tough
il y avait aussi les fans finis petite
fille qui criait mais il y avait aussi
les fadas saguenay - ouais jamais ouais
ouais ça va aller mais c'était pas
c'était plus du monde qui était
peut-être jaloux ou frustré après moi je
sais pas mais c'est et offre un petit
bout d'un pas pressé mais ça s'est calmé
quoi mène dans l'apparence du parfaite
et c'est un beau gars dont passé patrick
roy de jouer au hockey tout comme
l'apparence du goncourt kipchumba pour
qui tout va bien puis il ya quelque
chose qui gosses certaines personnes là
dedans c'est comme si c'est comme s'il
fallait enfin la voie restera encore un
peu plus que sept
mais les gens savent même pas si
j'arrive ses secrets à notre dame des
landes
on est tous humains les gens s'invente
invente que les riches pili biljana
rompt pas de problème qui estiment leur
vie seront bellm non tout le monde est
pareil tout le monde est pareil c'est
parce que juste
oui peut-être que ton par faisait de
l'argent par contre tu étais aussi
partout en même temps tu impôts vraiment
de titres au colorado à québec qui avait
été c'était sélectif quand même là la
vie d'un joueur de hockey
la vie de sa famille c'est tout je cite
hoffman agresseurs tipi tout cela
n'équivaut pas nécessairement de
l'argent l'argent est là pour payer
justement ce genre de ville
le luxe - mais moi j'ai vraiment une
belle enfance dans la main quand même
jusqu'à tac mais par son temps mais ça
va mes parents sont séparés l'austérité
plus tough la famille mais mon enfance
était quand même le fun pimont mon père
oui était parti souvent puis en vérité
mon pas raymond n'a pas eu de relation
vraiment jusqu'à l'âge de deux connectés
fait peut-être c'était parce qu'ils
étaient pas souvent à la maison plus de
kits mais j'ai quand même eu une belle
enfance ma mère était magnifique et
autres génomes incroyable qu'ils ont
gardé donné beaucoup beaucoup d'amour on
avait vraiment une famille taitei tête
d'un magnifique but était d'aller au
mans par joueur qui les jeudis vendredis
samedis on en avait un
puis on était tous des passionnés d'art
qui fait qu on up hippique à la radio
c'était magnifique adoré qu'à la radio
c'est sûr que peut-on te utd années
formatrices le français est plus
difficile un petit peu bougé tout un été
à l'école en anglais quand je te revenir
à québec je la scène pâte en anglais
aussi je me rattrape le plus que je peux
en parler avec ma femme ma femme
passerait bien français puis 1000m et en
tout en france est aussi le fait que de
plus en plus je commence à être capable
de lire des livres en français tu ne
t'es pas capable e45 fait que je me je
veux être plus québécois ou francophones
2-2 lanxade importé oui mais oui elle
est un cadeau mes parents m'ont donné
jeunes ce de pouvoir parler de l'un ses
images italie dans le monde parle
anglais français
ma femme à part quatre vingts minutes
texte comme je parlais tantôt du vrp
d'espèces de tournant que ça africains
quant eux d'acheter ce qu'est ce qui t'a
amené le kit spaemann fox je t'ai jetez
plus heureux dans le monde convient de
la société puis la façon dont je vivais
les le contrôle que les gens avaient sur
moi surtout dans l'industrie musicale
c'est moi j'étais avec mon amusé pendant
cette antenne avec aux erreurs picorer
était magnifique le même année j'avais
juste besoin de me détacher aux douanes
crazy perfectionniste puis je dors pas
la nuit
cela laisse le cerveau luyindula ne
totalisait moncheaux cammas va le monter
à qu'il faut j'écris nouvelle tonnes
j'ai pas fini sa phrase de forget qui la
prochaine fera autres excès s'arrête
jamais de tourner puis amman et j'ai
juste fait il n'en est rien à écrire
dessus hadji je suis pogné dans ce
groupe que je veux pas être plus je
voyais comme des artistes
à l'extérieur qui l'invoquent qui se
suicider puis j'ai bien pensé au suicide
une seconde mais moi je me disais j'ai
pas le goût de marans domaine je fais ce
que j'aime
j'imagine que j'ai eu pas de c'est ça je
me suis dit j'ai eu tellement pas de
dire fuck
imagine si j'aime plus que je fais c'est
map pack une passion et et j'ai acheté
le v1 et je suis partie un road trip est
juste allé me découvrir j'ai juste ça le
commencer le tout c'est spécial va se
parler de dépression puis tu sais le
cipi notamment une dialyse comme tu dis
tantôt et ses civilités
il doit être heureux une succès de la
tournée mais il ya quatre gardes les
chefs et des études l'adulte et le taux
de dépression chez les musiciens qui
font la tournée c'est si démesuré de ce
nom c'est vraiment pas difficile mais
vous pensez que c'est quoi penser que
c'est au moins quatre mois
ma théorie c'est que c'est la pression
de l'industrie non la pression des ndr
d'être là mais en version 3 - peut-être
c'est quand tu peux jamais de permettre
d'être sloppy jamais même s'il y en a
qui se le permettre mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est sur l'impression
que ce qui a amené tu veux être la mère
version de toi même tu veux tout le
temps plaire à tout le monde
non j'ai l'impression mais dont la
tournée pendant mais moi je pense qu'il
ya sûr mais je pense qu'il ya aussi des
trucs plus d'études et de thé jamais
chez vous tout intérêt à l'institut
construit rien du tout le temps un peu
tu essaies tu étais jamais romney puis
tu fais le parti plus toutefois plus tu
manges - j'ai jamais embarqué laddh 6e
mais ceci est un danger vis beaucoup
beaucoup tombent dedans parce que ça
peut être attirante
d'accord c'est souvent là dedans ça doit
être parce que ils tombent drogue puis
tu tombes dans l'alcool
et je pense années de rouler mais je
reconnais mais j'en connais des demandes
qui peut pas s'en passer de l'avis même
de nouvelles via la presse que c'est
vivre ça au rock là il y en a qui fixe
la rocade autour de moi de seppi s'est
haussé autodestructeur ouais bah jones
et le vix qui sont là je le vois puis ça
fait souvent défaut qui touche le fond
pour tout enlever
absolument mais moi il faut faire bien
attention porte sur true north patriots
c'était des rôles dans un documentaire
il parlait dit que au début c'est comme
le iphone aller ajouté tout ça devient
trop beau rien fait que je vais mettre
un petit peu d'excès demain dans ton
enfant avec tu aimes tu vas te prends un
shot avant ton chaud plat mais chute à
menton chose puis à ces faits tu prends
un verre avant ton show le voir c'est
plus à ces phénomènes la bouteille au
complet seul stage le des rameurs tout
le temps parce que sinon c'est plus
excitant joué huit ou neuf ans du monde
qui trippent c'est plus excitant de plus
de fonds bâtie sexuellement une dose
d'adrénaline d'amour un rush incroyable
qui a précipité sans pis ça dure 20
minutes après ça ça a fini par en
descente il eu des fois si tu veux
retrouver ce feeling y arrive par chaque
jour c'est fini le temps où tu moi j'ai
jamais c'est rare que je vais prendre un
verre points chauds me saoulé métier je
suis un petit peu gêné asseoir un
problème d'hiver où je veux me donner
une petite base pour embarquer sa sainte
brigitte objet
je pensais à cause du hockey j'ai jamais
eu besoin d'eux pour gérer le tour j'ai
réagi c'est moi je reprends ma p'tite
bière a pris et puis d'aller l'appui de
même du batave un show pas impossible je
serai jamais capable après ce qui a
choqué on peut faire de la poterie
encore la nuit là mais je les fais tu
sais tu connais pas je l'aï fait une
fois dans ma vie
a city je t'ai régine jouvray pour les
black eyed peas à morgane
c'était quand glover jane foster ont
existé je pensais que c'était un enfer
mais j'ai fait c'était mon premier gros
choc de ma vie en avant je pense y avait
sept huit ministères pas beaucoup de
monde en fait
puis après le show italie mme suleman a
fait excentrique donc sonic s'est couché
dans le parc dans le parking du cristal
il va nouer grosse soirée je me réveille
un téléphone manger à aimanter saint
damien
geagea rivaux ovale puis tu t'étais où
puis-je je vous messieurs n'arrêtait pas
de vomir voulait que j'étais avec votre
sac en plus soit ça qui me donnait 10
des manteaux de cuir
je me demande ce qu il faisait comme 40
d'or reçu l'appui jeu franchement source
engine et les mais je me suis dis jamais
de la vie que je refais cette erreur là
je n'ai jamais refait leur fait faire au
quotidien même y en a qui le font c'est
amy winehouse au quotidien la presse
ça finit jamais bien non suis je vois
pas d'un gros sites qui font ça dans les
journaux
taft tout te tue dessus dépasse tout ce
que tu faisais trop le partait pour toi
le temps pour maintenant tu reflète sur
ce tas dessus quand tu étais plus jeune
c'est parce que chez ça peut être un
musée coup ça peut être dans la roque et
tish et que la plupart des j'ai vu des
parts et des galères en porc qui virait
en crise l'étude mais ne tue dépasse
tout ce qui c'était comme fuck le site
ou match j'ai tout en contrôle
l'année dernière ça et eloi que l'on
sait téléphone mais encore une fois en
contrôle je me dis j les primes on
m'appelle on joue on aimerait ça va t-on
vers sa plage ou en gîte bas je me dis
que ali g moi ça que si tu prends mon
vélo que je peux vivre dedans plus que
ce soit à l'intérieur du beach pour que
je peux
vit l'expérience beach club veuille
vraiment mais j'ai tellement je faisais
à 7h30 les gens port d'onne jean paul
gillet moi j'ai acheté de l'alcool en
tulle et puis je me faisais des amis
mais je me parlait que le mans j'avais
goûté mouche terme si j'étais parti en
six mois a pas parlé avec personne
la fin j'ai même ma femme était pas le
tout le temps à une attaque deux membres
restants du tee shirt avant tout seul
fait que ça fait ça faisait du bien de
d'échangés puis de parler faire le party
en contrôle ne rien de plus faux il
avait dix mois et avoir du fun qui irait
mieux de te faire la fête en contrôle de
ses skis
oui d'annecy ce qui sauf faut que tu
saches quand arrêter quand tu sais que
ton corps le trop long un petit sexe va
quand même commencer à faire des erreurs
c'est un délice ces sales and impact
négatif sur les hautes sphères de ta vie
le foot pose un problème de football
négation c'est problématique car c'est
ce qui crée des problèmes c'est
l'excellent victimes quand tu disais
tantôt je parlais que tu avais été sex
addict pendant un but plus tu parles de
balance que parce que dans le mot
addictions et quand même une connotation
vraiment négative ce qui se passe que la
négative
non ben oui parce que maintenant les
lits en coupe quand je tente parce que
moi je taquine quelqu'un pendant 50 ans
puis tu veux pas tromper la la la la la
femme que tu exposes et demi ouais ça
fait mouche et au juge je suis vraiment
content tromper quelqu'un je trouve
c'est de la merde
donc je lui dis je les fais je les fais
plein de fois puis je ne peux pas et je
le regrette mais parce que j'ai eu du
fun en a qui risque qu'il fallait que je
le fasse puis j'ai vécu de quoi puis
j'étais en tournée tout le temps puis
j'avais le goût de baisers oui je
voulais vivre la petite vie de rock star
puis à chaque soir d'avoir une nouvelle
fille mais maintenant on dirait que dans
l'addiction way s'est essoufflé mais
c'est comme ça c'est comme la musique
est devenu quelque chose de vraiment
fait que j'ai mis beaucoup d'énergie
dans ma musique donc c'est comme si des
addictions sexe à baisser puis ça s'est
calmé avec la musique vraiment appuyé
une autre façon importante on prix bas
pour fois que ce soit 81 de quoi en ne
regardant je pensais parce que j'avais
arrêté de faire du hockey puis quitte
une roche incroyable fac on dirait que
moi j'avais pu me roesch être sa
patinoire de bramois pic la salle e
comme vraiment j'avais besoin de quelque
chose qui me stimule loin qui me
stimulait puis le cubain s'était se
plaint éventuellement magie trouver
d'autres stimulants dans ma vie donc ça
c'est plus c'est plus calme est ce que
j'adore encore le cul absolue
mais après combien de temps cette
période là c'était jusqu'à jusqu'à tac
je me suis fait deux blessés devraient
mener j'ai une ex blonde qui qui me
laissait que me trompe et puis c'est
radical j'ai raconté cette femme là que
j'avais le goût de changer
j'avais le goût d'être moins au cul
c'est comme cela que ça c'est comme
vraiment fait en même temps même temps
que la musique avec ce come back aurait
explosé un petit peu plus tout s'est
fait comme en même temps une période
charnière noir 1 puis la dent dans ton
couple actuellement puis on peut parler
de ce vol dans ton couple actuellement
ce qui est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui tousse c'est plus du tout dépensé
c'est plus du tout un problème c'est
plus du tout un os que vous avez est ce
que tu as trouvé une façon de gérer ses
de ce désir le différemment sans entrer
dans les détails le non non c'est moi ma
femme simone un coupe vent
c'est simple
on s'aime en fait nous on se parle puis
on fait ce qu'on disait ensemble on
trippe ensemble si jamais cause de
conflit le cul non non car quand tu
parles de tromper quelqu'un j'imagine
que la tromperie doit être à plusieurs
niveaux le sait la tromperie dans l'oeil
de la personne qui se fait tromper en
fait le puits quand quand établi des
parents m dans ta relation
j'imagine que ça peut se décliner de
plusieurs façons tromper quelqu'un et
puis quand tu ne parles de communication
pic de d'honnêteté noguès via c'est là
que la ligne en le style old chine
respecte sans pour ça ouais mais ta
question c'est quoi exactement
ben non mais c'est juste d'essayer de
définir parce que tu disais moi tromper
quelqu'un trop beau pour moi c'est aussi
cette demande ce serait ne pas le dire
de cacher le jouet dando ce qu'on fait
dans à quelqu'un qu'on aime plains pas
ça soit à fans ou un ami men's pour
cette petite vidéo de sony ericsson ne
put your cette bande louisiens de briser
l'utiliser le tromper c'est briser aussi
de l'entente qui était avec la personne
ou ce que tu sais qu est ce que la
personne avait quitté attend de toi tu
manques de respect de leur esprit de
respect et mon honnêteté absolue la
règle que je me mets c'est de dire est
ce que j'ai dit est ce que si elle
savait un temps réel ce serait collé
fait que ça lui ferait pas qu'elle
verrait pas ce que parce que je
comprenne y mettant dans un couple
ouvert
tu veux pas nécessairement voir ton
partei avec leur dire si je veux pas le
savoir mais là je te parle parce que
chic dans un couple vers des fois ça
veut pas dire que la personne vous de
voir tu dis que moi c'était ce qui est
la personne le savait au moment où est
ce que je faisais un book
au moment où ce que je prenne action est
ce que cela
dérangerait et quand est-ce que c'est
pas cette question là quant à ce qui se
passe proche de vote à positiver
question moi j'écris tous les jours mais
c'est la règle que je me suis donné
c'est la règle de la personne à qui je
suis le savait au moment où est ce que
ça se passe qu'est-ce que ça c'est vrai
que la répercussion cette personne
puisse avarie de personne en personne
c'est un fait unique de coupe sont
différentes aussi c'est vraiment
difficile à comparer avec étaient toutes
à femmes puis avec ton extenso dynamique
exercer tout le monde a le droit d'avoir
sa vue absolument oui puis en notant que
ce soit avec le cat est passé avec
qu'est ce qui a changé chez toi mais
dans ce voyage dans le vert dans le vert
bah écoute j'ai commencé à poser une
question est ce que j'aimais la musique
est-ce que j'ai même la musique est ce
que j'aimais assez ça pour me refaire
vivre tout ce finalement ben jeunes en
conclusion que absolument absolument js
puis je réalise et qui a tout les matins
champagne et ma guitare et mon petit
café puis j'écrivais plus j'écrivais
puis il y avait depuis je faisais plein
de pleine affaire aussi tout autour de
moi y avait plein d'actions ont fait que
j'ai fait plein d'enfants mais l'idée de
passer à autre chose puis de tourner la
page et à penser par l'esprit - ah ouais
ouais j'ai je me suis dit qu'est ce que
je vois qu est ce que je ferai j'avais
aucune des deux ou plus que je pouvais
faire en fait je me disais peut-être que
je pourrai partie 1 en australie avec
l'argent que j'ai mis de côté puis juste
peut-être continuer à voyager un peu
mieux
enfin pu mener demain mais les x
apparaît six mois puis je la vois pas
comprends-tu et puis moi des fois
j'écoute partir très fécond ça fait du
bien de partir mais oui puis quand tu
pars on dirait qu'on veut aller cherche
on veut trouver de quelque chose quelque
chose qui montre il ya quelque chose qui
manque si fait que j'avais j'avais je
sais pas j'avais besoin de demander à
l'est puis deux on dirait que c'est
comme si la question qu'est ce qui te
retrouves qu'est-ce que je t'envoie toi
qu'est-ce que je changerais même ta
réponse est excellent je sais qu'il y
avait je pense à quelque chose puis je
voulais plaisir penser mais ça m'a juste
vraiment puis pas d'avoir d'heure pour
une seconde puis de faire les choses qui
me rendait vraiment rue pie pas voir
cette pression le savez j'ai un besoin
de la dengue notamment qui c'est qui se
connaît puis qui sait trouver leur
bonheur à pikine qui agace à paul
c'était par les sociétés la pression
mais je la sens pas chez tout un genre
de dire il faut que je sois conforme à
siwa si tu veux juste que tu veux petit
comme tu veux ou je me trompe mais là ça
fait comme ça fait trois ans quand même
que je lis je me sentais dans ce machin
dans ce moule
ouais mais c'est ce qu'on sait ce dans
la société aujourd'hui c'est sûr que en
sortant l'album je sais que je vais être
obligé de faire certaines enfants qu'ils
ont eus nécessaire pour que ça
fonctionne
m j'ai été obligé de rembarquer dans le
moule de ma façon
c'est cela même si une certaine manière
de refaire à rester à quai en restant
soi-même ouais pitt et des fois ça veut
dire aussi pas plaire à tout le monde
mais plaire aux gens qui tiennent les
jantes en croit la dre personnes leur
plaira rue vraiment quitté mode à mes
artistes préférés au québec c'est
souvent des originaux souvent du monde
justement qui font leur truc même piste
un peu oui mais tu es supporter haïti ou
tel métier c'est quasiment mieux ça que
de vouloir plaire à tout le monde
puis d'efforts de quoi de mais c'est
vraiment plate a su plaire à tout le
monde c'est beau c'est plutôt le temps
de faire ton notons tout répit puis
quand tu vois que les gens embarquent n
est bouffé les ouï dire bah tu embarques
pas parce que c est qu il aura servi la
recette qui marche et c'est sur l'île
bagne marc pasquet niveau adéquat les
gens vont dire adore aussi mais si t'es
pas vrai dans ta démarche artistique
mennecier de quoi que tu fais pour les
mauvaises raisons
ça se sent j'en suis convaincu
qui ça ça marche moins l'attitude que tu
dégages sur la scène ou en entrevue
votre tout le temps qu un feed 100%
tarif 5 e crois-tu fil global ce qu'une
chance que tu fais pis programme neuf
dates du fun sur ce thème les gens le
savent
oui c'est mon côté j'étais stressé et
[ __ ] sécuroute crois pas 100% des
enfants
ça sent aussi mais ça ça prend jamais le
mans jamais croire en toi c'est toi même
tu y crois pas aux étoiles ouais c'est
vrai je pense c'est vrai c'était pas
soin de préciser conférence et la
musique que j'aime pas ce que veut dire
tu écrit des textes que tu aimes pas ça
la rive mais oui c'est ça qui est capté
une recette qui existe cette lacune avec
ta voix
ça se peut que tu aimes pas la recette
avec ce soit pas la formule pour toi
est-ce que vous partirez l'on se
retourne en l'air parce que j'aime ce
est-ce que vous partirez vous en verre
ou en voyage à ce que vous avez déjà
fait un trait par et de prendre un petit
break demi un peu de cash de côté qui
doit partir à l'aventuré en back pack
ouais moi j'ai devenu dans la fin moi
j'ai tout le temps su que j'adorais
voyager
le temps essayé de voyager le plus
souvent que je pouvais à chaque année
mais j'avais fait des longs voyages
parce que en faisant de la musique avec
la carrière dépend d'un mode pour trois
mois c'est ce que tu as construit ce qui
peut le perdre assez rapidement moi je
trouve tout le monde qu'ils m'appellent
mes livres il faudra trouver quelqu'un
d'autre va revenir
l'appartement est vraiment spécifique ce
fac moi j'ai tout le temps à qui j'ai un
deux semaines de luz le juge pas je
pense que je parties au costa rica et
monext parties au liban une partie avait
fait le plafond regrettez vous pas ce
que j'aime voyager ses 17 ans maintenant
que ça serait pas se met tant que
parrain m peter viennent finalement ait
à rentrer dans ton moult c'est dunkerque
le jef est déjà rentré dans son moule
dans le fond ça c'est clair
jallet ma vie savoir si j'allais ma vie
j'aime ce partir deux semaines
vu l'expérience goûter la nouvelle
nourriture votre nouvelle zafour
rencontrer de nouvelles personnes c'est
ça le voyage
un concentré nouvelle expérience puis
j'adore soutien intervient ici pi2 comme
un espèce de bagages des plus torrides
autres y compris d'une nouvelle affaire
on y était puis c'est comme que les deux
semaines qui est où est ce que tu as
l'impression que si rien passé ici
puisqu'elle montre exactement au même
point toi tu es comme fait un esti bout
de chemin ce jeu sa maison en deux
semaines de concentrer d'expérience mais
je laime avis en même temps tu piges
j'aime aussi construire tranquillement
par le travail par la discipline puis
par une seule la persévérance des
besoins c'est une belle vie city fer qui
s'est un peu ce et moi c'est mon souhait
le plus cher mènent ces deux de joint
l'utile à l'agréable de joindre des
projets qui vont faire voyager afin de
les faire de la musique par tout ça
serait ça toujours été se cache t gêne
car je rentre osséja par musique je
m'étais jamais que j'aime voyager des
jeux j'avais que genre partir six mois
par tirana serait foot et je me suis dit
mais se repose travail pratique devient
bon
puis à m'amener le bon timing est arrivé
en faisant la musique puis le toit faire
les deux choses que tu aimes ahmed 7
jours 10 mois si je partais pas à
occupation double j'avais déjà tout
m'ont smaghi de près le plan c'était
j'imagine moto ouais j'avais mon salaire
qui est parti seul but d'être quatrième
le non non juste à la porte d'entrée
mais je m'étais acheté un sac avec ma
tante de places dyslipidémies que
j'avais mon sac était faite c'est que je
resterai à perdre ma moto puis je
supportais pas aux dés je partais six
morts c'est que 6,6 non je le ressens du
x cause du genre à travers ces jusqu'en
californie après ok fixer ses tarifs
relations déjà annoncés dans ce cas
descendu je l'aurais de floride parce
que j'aurai travers ce qui s'arrêtait
seul à rabat par le barman sud - exonhit
s'arrêtait seul plan supportait pas aux
dés tout était fait les préparatifs que
j'avais pu d'appart en moto en plus des
biens
j'aurais vraiment aimé se faire ça puis
piloquet ski qu'est-ce qui tarde est 2e
ça serait dessus et inclut ce que tu
pars coupe de mourir ça serait sûrement
pop mal pour une relation de couleur en
sport on à la dynamique
je pense que quand cette dynamique là
même dans mon sens inverse
je pense que moins je serai
particulièrement heureux kaka met sur
pause qu'on construit ensemble pour
partir le tir par contre c'est sûr que
c'est une fois tu y mettons que
l'infrastructure mettons trois ans dans
92 maintenant infrastructures par
exemple du studio des projets que je
fais avec elle voir d'établi c'est sûr
que disparaître derrière des noms
derrière des marques
le skate ph canton de disparaître
derrière ce que je crée qui si ça peut
me permettre de faire ce serait
idéal vraiment certaine est beau ce
serait incroyable mais là voudraient
dessus partir avec toi sk par trek doigt
puis alfred sur ce genre de voix je ne
sais pas si affreux ce genre de voyage
le jeu c'est qu'à voudrait-on 1 m j'ai
fait en hiver ce voyage le mans nantes
ont vu leurs noms dans le premier voyage
evotec ma femme en tant qu'un bon la
ville ou un chat on a fait le sud
waziristan mais pas de pas de tout le
côté droit mais on n'a juste pas tout le
sud-ouest puis c'était incroyable talent
therese moins six d'or on est des
granges l'imam hussein est beau voyage
en fait je te le souhaite de le faire
parce que c'est encore plus hâte de
vraiment de partir par deux langues le
code s'cusez moi j'étais coupé le vase y
est je vois c'est sûr qu'avec elle
voudrait partir un gars de 3-6 3-6 mois
mais je ne sais pas si ce genre de
voyage là ce serait le voyage parce
qu'après avoir du plaisir
moi je suis que ce serait le genre de
voyage que j'en aurais beaucoup mais je
sais pas si elle se serait le genre de
l'étape de trouver du monde dans ta vie
qui fit dans n'importe quoi qui fait
asti que je vous souhaite tout ce jeu
tellement chanceux avoir rencontré ma
femme parce que dans n'importe quoi et
cheveux femme à femme puis - smaf
akindès run je peux aller estime arraché
dans un festival à burning man comme je
peux aller frei kazan h au parc pour
faire un trekking de 14h 15h dormir dans
mon temps je comprends tu peux faire
tout avec elle aussi ses rangs
aujourd'hui c'est rentrer c'est vraiment
je trouve que je souhaite que les gens
trouvent ou ou comme tu es comme toi
budget aussi ça peut devenir c'est les
gens j'ai l'impression la mesure à
sortir de leur zone de confort -
vraiment ça fait tellement du bien de
sortir de sa zone de confort j'ai besoin
de ma love being en chrome propose
toujours le voyage de mme ainsi que ceux
où il va dormir enfin quelle température
que je mangeais semaine
c'est se mettre en danger la liberté aux
orres oui mais le feeling des libertés
humaines et on repart rapidement parce
que c'est la vie fait qu'il est aux
responsabilités et pression on est tous
mes sens est vraiment libre il n'y a pas
de meilleur phénix systems filet
justement juste avant ou des camps puis
même en allant des titres ge avait plus
rien j'avais ma moto oui mon sac de
voyage les a sentis c'est surtout la vie
moi j adore g/j regarder votre vote
rodez parce que sans expérience mais je
t'ai adoré merci je veux non vraiment je
trouvais ça lit de pose et puis moi j'ai
tout le temps voulu faire une
un show de mangue j'aurais voulu faire
l'animation va s'y trouve ça le fun ne
s'est pas être quoi la banque et qui
m'intéressent qui est une chance l'a
jamais fait mais mais mais mais mais
c'était quelqu'un jarret jarret et thé
vert je trouve que taio cruz neige
étaient telles par habituellement à ces
aides comme jouer des jeux puis à
trouver en moi si je fait savoir par
siam enfin sa voie tout était comme ben
oui ça arrive on va lever
c'est exactement mais pas les mêmes dans
vie aussi évidemment vu du stock et je
suis 100 % ce qui a été montré à t'aimer
jeu quand même que du gaz goguette
allez vous chercher comme by phone i way
vous le faites vous le faites au mcs
soit moi je pense le fourbe accents
nettement brave j'essaie de faire un max
de haut de forme
chaque jour moi chaque jour je me lève
le matin puis j'essaie de tout faire les
choses que je veux faire j'essaie de
m'améliorer dans tout j'essaie
d'apprendre une verge à faire j'essaye
de faire du sport
j'essaye de faire le meilleur podcast
pas ses séries phares le meilleur show
possible j'essaie d'être meilleur le
lendemain à chaque jour mais je sais
aussi c'est au tpi en même temps un
certain point des fois c'est chez nous
il ya parce que ça aussi c'est une
pression c'est aussi ce teint c'est un
moule que cette bd de vouloir être tout
le temps plus mais oui et vous doit être
d'autant plus ça peut devenir pesant
c'est le fun parce que bad cale sur 5,7
des barmans d'accord faut c'est ce qu'on
apprend de fond faut apprendre à wayne
she tries to match ça faut apprendre ces
kits off ça qu'on ne peut pas encore moi
je ne vais pas encore exactement
atteindre les claquettes à l équilibre
parfait même si l'histoire d'une ville
c'est atteindre 7 à la désigne étude
profonde manuscrits tout l'espoir de ta
vie sont comblés mais si on n'y arrivera
jamais média désire tellement plus
d'outils aujourd'hui c'est que la
méditation yoga beaucoup plus de doute
si qui avait dante avant d'en tester
comme il y avait de la drogue juste
qu'un monde rex est la seule affaire qui
pouvait nous maintenant il n'ya pas
juste la drogue il ya tout plein
d'affaires extraordinaire même si tout
exister mais tout était pas comme intesa
diogo dante dans mail ou de fatigue mais
aujourd'hui c'est quand même pâques qui
fait du yoga c'est le fatah doit
tellement il fait du bien on y est
tellement plus d'outils pour nous
balancer dans le trio gauche mais sans
la catégorie activités physiques si je
pense que c'est essentiel à un équilibre
des relations humaines avec les gens
autour de toi tes amis ta famille et
tous ceux qui un jour des relations
étaient aussi je pense que c'est
essentiel d'après ce que tu tu accomplis
dans quelque chose ce qui est à ce que
tu te dépasse tout ce titre tout ceci
c'est d'allier ce titre des bonnes
habitudes de vie mais ça ça change tout
les remaniements la méditation c'est
quelque chose de nouveau aussi qu'ils
ont qui plus dans le discours maintenant
qu'on parlait pas temps avant qu'on se
rend compte tous les bienfaits de ce
coup de mou
jus mais on en fait tout les jours la
méditation ne réalise pas qu'on en fait
c'est tout juste de regarder un film n'a
pas même une or il faut ça nous arrive
le vin pour 20 minutes là on pense à
rien on écoute le film primé par le das
militaire le nude blacks ko tout ce qui
est autour de dépenser pour cette offre
ne me dit t'es juste de t'asseoir puis
de pensée pour une minute il
ouais qu'ils jugent probable un papa
mais que j'utilise un petit comme
l'écouté de la musique des fois la
musique écouter les sons pour juste
oublié tout mais c'est difficile la
méditation à mieux ça vaut la peine
d'aller là dedans sa bonne foi du bien
comme manny t on a fait de la pohdh cast
avec la soirée ph un podcast qui était
qui et exclusive pour les abonnés
piquionne puis on ne parlait plus
méditation pis si on dit j'ai des amis
qui ont fait ce remède on aller dans des
monastères genre et deux semaines puis
juste méditer puis ou s'ils se lancer
complètement pour la parler tu me dis tu
avais 14 heures par jour se lève à 5
heures du matin
by cc c'est vraiment des expériences moi
je n'ai pas fait des gens qui ont fait
ça c'est comme une chose les plus durs
parce que tu t'es construit tout seul et
se construit tout il reste plus rien
sauf toi tient toutes les addictions 2
tv qu'ils soient positives ou négatives
toutes étaient petites habitudes sont
pilotés fait là il était justement dr
même ta respiration puis on sent pas
pensé 3 rien qui premiers jours de brain
droite avis même se confrontent ou cv
tout ce que tu t'en fou c'était bien
vrai ça les gens oublient d'être bien
avec ses appuis ce pitch et dans les
milieux d'affaires c'est moi je suis
premier trou pas de thème pitcher gauche
à droite qui fera millions de projets il
a tout le temps l'oder ci-dessus
ci-dessus seriez douce et je le sais pas
j'ai pas répondre à ça mais ça viendra
le manquez pas est ce que je sais
pourquoi je pas capable d'arrêter
dernière main et j'ai vu comme un wake
up call par rapport à toute seule j'ai
perdu mes cheveux
[ __ ] moi j'ai trois plaques de cheveux
qui sont justes on puis c'est toujours
ce qui est stressé ben je pensais pas
mais tu étais bon mais je pense à
l'export loin de la natation
peut-être très bon sûrement pour ré
pressé ce comme ignorer un peu
l'éléphant dans la pièce mais il en est
que le stress il semble physiquement
puis des fois deux fois non vous voyez
l'homme est diplômé la face c'est sûr
mais possiblement que je le sentais
physiquement mais que je n'étais pas
capable de définir une sensation t le
stress moi je croyais que c'était comme
avant une course de natation l'été comme
avant une grosse compétition je pensais
que c'était sur le stress
mais le stress ça peut aussi à un stress
constant
puis dernièrement et ses passes et chris
mandat fort dans ma vie où est ce que le
j'avais un million de trucs constamment
à penser puis comme tu disais trouver
l'équilibré entre toutes ces affaires là
mais eu la pression que je me mettais
j'imagine a su trouver l'équilibré de
force en place de juste un effort hockey
en fin semaine j'ai je pourrais aller
voir ma famille je pourrais travailler
ici je pourrai faire aller voir des amis
je pourrais faire xy truc je vais juste
médecin tué juste mettra of complètement
en fin de semaine je fais rien
puis ce jeu je me suis jamais permis
avant mais ça fait du bien kiev a
aujourd'hui je vais pas courir
aujourd'hui je vais pas aujourd'hui je
vais faire faux car je veux pas penser à
personne je vais prendre je vais fermer
mon cell je vais pas répondre aux
messages textes qui rentrent parce que
c'est depuis au destin constant struggle
d'avoir tout le temps mon cell cendre
est dans quelque chose qui vienne puis
de toujours sentir qui serait bon pas
dans la minute du retard des projets
juste faire je vais enlever des trucs
dans ma vie va enlever des projets je me
concentrais sur certaines affaires ça va
et quelques on le fait ça aussi mène
clairement ce que j'aimerais que cammas
avait été cette semaine c'est fait le
plus grand bien
ouais ouais qu'est ce que fait juste
chez la maison loin de reach l'échiné je
suis chez nous ma blonde était à québec
je dédie ce site à leuna date est
maintenant venu le parti ne va pas
penser que juste fait j'aimerais penser
légumes un peu moi j'ai filé chez nous
ça m'a fait vraiment du bien puisque je
me suis dit après c'est que j'ai à les
bloquer des plages horaires
parce que c'est quand tout roule pour
des moments de rencontres planifie rien
to book quitter donc qu'est-ce que tu
fais samedi mais le mettons une fin de
semaine de libre dans trois semaines
tu diaz une fin de semaine du livre ça
va être mieux mais là tu vois bouquet
quelque chose d'ici là c'est sûr que tu
veux quelque chose contre le fait que
les j'ai pris mon calendrier j'ai dû
séjourner là je fais je pars en tant que
personne et moi cette fin de semaine là
puis quelqu'un va me proposer avec est
situé 7 fonctionne et là je peux pas
mettre ses bouquets m'excuse pour toi
pour moi c'était qu'ils ont baptisé main
oui oui j'ai pris les nerfs ça c'est
vraiment vraiment wake up call puis je
me disais dans toutes les études sur la
longévité pour ralentir le processus de
vieillissement
la chose qui ressort le plus souvent
c'est le stress tab 1 botte alimenter
man show king bien si ton corps est
constamment stressé sur vieillir plus
vite va développer plus de maladies du
vote de faire ça
puis ces problématiques dans une société
où est ce qu il faut tout le temps tu
sois meilleur unis l'autre faut tout le
temps que tu postes au max pour je
voudrais envoyer quelque chose mensah
capoté dans ce bois capote et pis ce que
tu dises existe gold est ce que je
m'abstiens majima john terry quelque
chose terrorisme ne s'éteint pas de cas
sur youtube je me trompe le dit non le
mais je dois te l'envoyer pis ils disent
que you can't you
en fait je vais te l'envoyer même pitre
vos besoins il faut que je le crois en
m1 pige j'aurais pas du sable
1 j'aurais pas de sable un an que ça
pouvait créer autant de répercussions et
je dois je les ai vus physiquement j'ai
perdu des cheveux puis comme
physiquement j'ai eu un problème qui
était lié au stress directement ces cas
qu'on arrête ces moments là qu'on prenne
fin de semaine qu'on répond plus au
téléphone on se rend compte après
chrysler continue de tourner le monde
paraît teen cwid se préparer à faire un
peu trop peut-être au monde et je sors
je te dis que tu devrais partir ouais ça
vote le têt le way meetic en chef de the
party au pérou deux semaines sans faire
d einstein scène c'était incroyable ces
malades puis pendant toute la première
semaine gpo checker mancelle
j'ai pas eu accès internet plus je peux
regarder des craintes il y mène
c'est comme si je me remettais à être
moi c'est comme si je recommençais
arrivée jean gens commencent à arriver
mais ne soutenait le mirail j'ai
recommencé à aceh qu'ils étaient j'ai
recommencé à faire plein d'amis qui j'ai
ouvert mon cell une semaine plus tard
puis c'était la tempête je le bats rose
ans et demi tous déjà j'ai manqué sa
bride ses pistes le sait comme acquis il
vraiment existe mais pis mais tu nous
qui donne vraiment c'est quoi le vrai
monde
farkas développeurs human beings mais
pour moi le vraiment
quitterie bay qui voyagent et puis qui
vivait ça pour moi ici c est hachette
on a obtenu avec le souhaitent et vanter
ses jambes quand quand tu recules petit
dit tout les concepts qu'on connaît son
la création humaine même le langage on
est les mêmes musulmans
biologiquement kevlar 70000 avons été
des chasseurs cueilleurs puis nos
existences ont rien à voir rien en
commun
c'est fou ce que c'est on a quelqu'un on
a un bagage génétique fait que tu y est
on a certaines limitations mais sinon
tout le reste le partage des
connaissances et les technologies ça
c'est incroyable t on qu'on se voit des
réalités des prêts réalité en fait on
concevoir des abstractions qui est lui
même le sentiment qu'on savait pas du
tout commencé à percevoir
puis je savais une couple de fois que
j'en parle pas de 15 m le livre ses
pièces de yuval à marine
si je travaille fait comme ça s'appelle
une brève histoire de l'humanité t il
pas des premiers humains a aujourd'hui
fait carrément l'histoire d'humanité en
condensé pin qui justement tu dit
salzbourg sheets et toutes les choses
auxquelles qu'on croit ailes argentées
l'argent c'est l'argent comme tel tu
peux pas le manger ne peut pas bien avec
peu pour rien faire avec c'est une
abstraction tout les codes tout les
seconds construit toutes ses bases et
labour semaine c'est la bourse nestea
d'abstraction là ça existe pol ccc l'est
où la religion une attraction et tout se
confondent nos sociétés sait pas écrire
le code génétique celle ci comme non
mais on y va parce qu'on est on est
parce que on et j'ai l'impression qu'on
est trop intelligent pour ce qu'on est
vraiment fait qu'on plomb les dames on
le voit on est on a foutu la main wayne
est un puits
on va essayer de se rattraper juste mais
je pense qu'on va se rattrape t on voir
réussir quelque part de rattraper
certaines choses mais certaines choses
qu'on way son fouet
ça va piquer à chaque année quelque
chose qui m'arrive quelque chose qui
chaque jour ça fait 6 baleine n'est qu'à
retrouver au japon sa peau de cendrillon
c'est ridicule ce qui on est on est
vraiment sur gris et l on veut tellement
faire de l'argent on veut tellement
avant du pouvoir ses moyens c'est comme
si on était des kids avec 47 on est tu
es super jeunes dans ces six nouveaux la
technologie évolue tellement rapidement
ces nouveaux qu'on a tous ce pouvoir-là
des mois qu'on peut à ce point le
modifier et environnement perreault des
conséquences sur ce qui nous entoure
puis on n'a pas la maturité du juste
pour la beauté en maturité dans 24 à
haut niveau global au niveau de l'espèce
la maturité de mer dit pas qu'on utilise
vraiment marre tous les soldes parle non
mais j'ai toutes les technologies juste
le faire parce que moi je trouve qu'il
est des loots in situ l'utilisent comme
info le ce extraordinaire est vraiment
plus intelligent avec sol aurait dû
chercher une question un mot à une
endroit pour blue on est plus les plus
intelligents mais son intelligence key
externe à notre cerveau soit pas
l'intelligence qui est l'oeuvre amant
puis l'avait voulue par case d'organes
avec
par le sort imagine si on pourrait
connecter les deux semaines car là on
est déjà des cibles ne serait pas
instantanée mais nous avons toujours su
au bout de la main le téléphone c'est de
par leur première étape de devenir un
surhomme devenir un petit transhumanisme
que la libye et l'egypte la technologie
pour devenir notamment des demi dieux
on va tout finir des mesures tout de
finir qu'on va avoir toutes les
informations de la possible accessibles
instantanément pont pour communiquer
avec les humains sont instantanément
éventuellement si on se trouve des trucs
pas c'est faux ça détruit pas ma vie moi
le juge est bas en dessous et à
l'aisselle avec les la télé tout c'est
moi ma femme plus on est potes pour ne
pas n'écoute pas terry moi j'écoute
netflix une faute tu en as tu as fait
cambiasso mais j'adore les documentaires
j'adore maintenant à m'instruire sa pige
encore une fois je trouve une balance de
puits de la vie c'est comme n'importe
quoi le téléphone aux cordes à liszt et
s'entraîner moi je dois club maintenant
piste et ça me fait tellement du bien
effective sur mon mac line int 4 5 après
son jeu je reviens là dessus je checke
me mets à face sur instagram a fortement
mais je déteste ces stages ne le fait
pas mouche peu d'argent moneo instiguant
moi c'est pour partager partager pipes
of je veux que les gens voyagent veux
que les gens voient le mans cette année
richesse incroyable de sortir de deux du
québec
tu es venu coupe d'année le même dans ma
famille à moi il ya des gens qui ont
jamais sorti québec jamais vu l'oceane
john milton
j'ai dit j'ai jamais vu le sien de ma
vie rock croyable que je veux que les
gens voyagent veut que les gens
rencontrent des gens d'autres peuples
puis tu vois quel point le monde est
magnifique
parce qu'il ya pas juste de faire
l'argent vie peut-être ponia maison pid
comme ceux dits oui c'est beau parra
tape base amazon mais tabarnak mais non
vie on vit sur une une affaire kidal par
ancien mais dans une univers cosmos une
boule mains avec de l'eau tu me vois la
visite est malade c'est une scène doit
bien sûr on en subit cadres du fpi
une des phrases qui est dit qu'un qui
parle de que l'être humain le temps
l'éternel insatisfait qui dit à des gens
qui font des milliards de dollars mais
qui rase des forêts au complet pour
enfants encore plus puisse allah
résonnait beaucoup en moi
suite aux podcasts puis c'est
incompréhensible
plus j'y pense - je comprends ce que
souvent on y pense pas que la vie est
comme ça c'est sûr mais plus j'y pense
- ça fait ça au moins ça fait du sens
qu'à des gens qui ont le même code
génétique que moi qui porte des actions
comme celle le plus en plus on y pense
plus à risque
lise monde évidemment
est ce qu'une fusée celle ci met men's
quand les gens ont goûté à à quelque
chose qui l'ont qui ont mis ce peuple on
règle ça finit plus ce n'est pas tout le
monde qui demandent c'est comme ça que
j'admire beaucoup de mon père mon père
aurait pu continuer à faire je vois
hockey à faire faire plus d'argent ou à
partir de business dans quelque chose
puis investir dans des compagnies de
faire plusieurs
un pis on n'est juste pas dit pourquoi
tu as beaucoup de faire plus d'argent
dans une tente près frère quelques
semaines du cachet d'où le meur à fin
mai je peux faire votre vie puis simon
l'avait un peu cette mentalité-là de
juste parce qu'ils aiment puis 2-2
d'être satisfaites
seul problème c'est qu'on n'est jamais
satisfait d'un humain on dirait on veut
tout le temps plus parce que c'est
vraiment dans notre dîner on est on
vraiment idiot de studio les sims sont
arrêtées d'ici sm 58 sebban funk soul
fan avoué
cette baisse est le fun c'est vrai que
c'est le fun ii jamais cherché le
confort chercher à être correct
monétairement pas avoir ce stress le
supplémentaires la fco est ce que ce
soit je comprends mais tu arrives à un
point inquiétant parce est le meilleur
exemple
qu'est-ce qui aurait fait avec plus
d'argent c'est quoi qui peut pas faire
maintenant qu'il aurait rendu plus
heureux s'il a fait plus d'argent
notamment t il ya sûrement fait dans sa
vie plus d'argent que la moyenne des
gens m'ont formé leur ville mais qui est
pourquoi on aurait fait plus boss de
poing verbe lui jouer au hockey était
payé pour ce tank est finie qu'est-ce
qui tu veux je fasse avec plus d'argent
j'en ai plus que ce que j'en ai besoin
j'ai plus d'argent que ce que j'en ai
besoin pour être 100% ou 100% heureux
par rapport à ce que l'argent pourrait
m'amener au fait pourquoi mais pourquoi
tout ce que je dis on en parlait
autrefois justement quand ma soeur je
pense pas que mon rythme de vie
ceci me mafart vraiment de l'argent
éventuellement je pense pas que mon
rythme de vie va changer certaines
choses
en fait c'est surtout votre père ne pas
être d'aller manger de la merde
c'est ce week end une petite affaire
qu'on va faire mais je pense d'abord
êtes à bord c'est mon nom c'est moi j'ai
eu la chance de moi je m'achetais 1989
look et puis mon deuxième vie en 1988
jeu
j'aime les vieilles à fabienne michon
qui nous demandaient 26
si j'investis toit puis je te jette un
brin nous envient l'année 2019
on passe à un goût d'amertume non
pourquoi
ouais parce que j'aime je me soucie pas
besoin du gros luxe de la grosse patate
chaude à poney dans le moteur je me sens
quelque chose brise par logement en vo
esteba californie puis j'aime vous
n'êtes pas du tout bord de la route je
sais pas je donne je me suis pouvoir go
sépia arraché de la famille je sais pas
de quoi quil phone de ne pas avoir le
gros luxe biais du monde qui sont pas
capables de ça aussi c'est quels sont
les différents puis je pense que j'ai
j'ai pas pour vous autres mais moi j'ai
commencé à ça fait peut-être 202 à menin
j'accepte les gens comme ils sont on
change repos l'ifac gens je peux emmener
il faut arrêter ce fort chicomba
pourquoi fait si pourquoi fait ce
pourquoi qu'à me tromper programme est
pas trompé i know what the stooges ou
des six coins de l'hexagone sous bail à
ma vie avec toi aux normes c'est ça les
gens mais tu peux travailler sur toi tu
peux t'améliorer tout peut changer en
forme et dessus change pas vraiment je
pense les gens par rinse disputa
milliards étaient mais vraiment le
courage de revenir à la barre bandits
il ya des luttes et le corps d'une
personne ça va rester son corps je peux
tu peux ne peut pas transformer une
personne en ce que tu voudrais qu'elle
souhaite maintenant que mes temps de
réfléchir à quel point c'est dur de
changer quelque chose par rapport à toi
même mais à quel point c'est dur de
changer quelque chose par rapport à
quelqu'un mais sur ce que tu dis là moi
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment
que je que je travaille sur ce pour moi
d'art oui je sais ce que tu en dis c'est
magnifique
parce que - territoire courant de dire
je sais que sa fille ait des gens qui
savent même fort qu'un point mais c'est
nouveau le niveau que je commençais à
réfléchir à ça du rock et il ya vraiment
cgo j'ai été élevé carrément aux milieux
conservateurs
avec quoi cette mentalité là
nécessairement de déduire la façon de
vivre sa vie c'est juste la mienne c'est
ma façon à moi de ma vie c'est ma façon
à moi de voir les choses ça veut pas
dire que c'est la façon la façon de
vivre une vie ça veut pas dire que c'est
la façon de tout le monde de vivre une
vie moins pis moi se laisser aller leur
que tu dis que ça fait quelques années
que tout appris à gérer moi c'est
quelque chose que je sais qu'il faut que
je fasse faut que j'apprenne à faire ça
parce que sinon je n'ai jamais pouvoir
accepter des gens avec une vision
différente de ma vie depuis
une des personnes qui m'ont aidé
beaucoup à faire sécher numara ses
cendres et qu'en fait qu aucun cas
n'était à od c'est évidemment c'est pas
le genre de conversation qui ont été
montrés à tv mais des fois on était
longtemps s'y attablent soir quand tout
le monde est couché agissent par les
piscines n'inquiète pas la même vision
de la vie - ses cendres il 6-1 puis puis
tu sais quand tu prends le temps de
parler à une personne qui t'expliquent
sa vision des choses qui t'explique
comment il fit sa vie sur plusieurs
aspects puis que ça fait du sens c'est
pas la mienne mais flotte pour lui et
xaris bien c'est bien lui pas bien c'est
bien quand même
mais exactement c'est ça php tout le
monde tout le monde focki bild bild lors
idées puis lors faut qu'ils aient view
that we were après c'est bien mais un
site faut jusqu'à taxe est quittée et
accepte que tout le monde est différent
pis puis effectivement c'est pas le nom
qu'il exprime tout le temps bien
puissance ben c'est sûr tu peux il y va
de montrer sa vision puis dans le fond
sa vision a marché c'est un plus un plus
un égale trop mais toi ton tout à fait
du un plus un plus un -2 plus serein
plus comment dessus ces jeux ça le juste
tout se voit différemment mais l'huile
et elle expliqué de sa façon ça
fonctionne puis je suis même passé a
fait dix ans que je viens de faire le
jeu mais c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'il est
ce que je trouve magnifique en fait
c'est quand qu'on accepte les visions
des autres et on y est on y pratique oui
c'est marseille ok coup in our work but
your grave une fin une affaire qui lui
fait que tu aimes une vision de ce que
tu la ramènes je te rends compte
quelqu'un d'autre se ramène un petit
quelque chose que quelqu'un de puits
afin si tu vas arriver si tu fais ta
propre idée sur plaine pas tendre avec
tout ce que tu as autour de toi puis
devient devient tous les publics je peux
entendre si vous parliez de que ça
revenait toujours au corps que les gens
changeaient pas réellement je pense pas
que c'est vrai je pense que je pense que
tu te laisses ou non l'opportunité de
changer puis si tu te complais vraiment
puis moi je veux dire je suis en plein
dedans sur un site complet à dire non
moi si je dois rester comme ça à
quelques nuances près je pense que si
cette limite est dans la tasse et
chimiques studio 6 1
ces scientifiques chimiques je vais
t'envoyer se comprend pas mais je
travaille les blocs il oui c'est le
désir de changer d'os et chimiques
si dan sexton
ton cerveau fonctionnent qui sont
envoyées de la compétence pas capoté
jeudi le sabbat tout savoir répond on a
plain d'avoir jeu ça me fait chier de
pas savoir c'était quoi non moi je pense
que je pense que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut absolument pas se dire de soi
- parce qu'il faut essayer d'être mais
en version essayer de s'améliorer sur
tous les aspects forts essayé de changer
quelques noms c'est ça alors c'est clair
ça je suis d'accord avec toi tu peux pas
partout ça va marcher mais ton dans une
relation c'est un marché que cette
personne mais si advient comme ce nom ce
sauf que sauf que toi j'ai l'impression
que plus grande erreur que tu peux force
ouais c'est ce mot incertaine elle m'a
tu peux changer pour la meilleure
version toi même investir des patrons je
le sais il ya des patrons qui sont
offerts tabarnak vraiment sauf que ils
sont effaçable mais il ya des pâtes et
des mauvais plis des mauvais par tonne
puis à des personnalités aussi où il ya
des valeurs si toi tu es triquint de
mettre quelqu'un qui est ambitieux dans
sa carrière a battu ni positif ni
négatif suisse un trait de caractère
la presse people ça va t'amener du
positif dans certaines soirées ta vie
peut-être négatif dans d'autres mais
après ce est-ce que ce que tu reproches
à la personne avec qui tu es d'être
comme ceux qui l'acceptent assez juste
une un trait de caractère une valeur ses
atouts compétitifs compétitif ça amène
ça met du hull 3 % dans ta vie tu as été
le meilleur jeu dangereux auquel
adhèrent universitaire très prenante il
s était pas compétitif moi j'ai pas
aussi compétitif que toi qui se passe en
grande partie ce qui a été fait grâce et
moi pis toi dans la carrière dès lors
jean leguay boucler facture et
compétitif c'est positif on a même temps
c'est un trait de caractère qui permit à
négative tenant jusqu'à quel âge parce
que c'est c'est prouvé la compétition
c'est un énorme stress en pause cns
mais c'est sûr que d'après moins que
j'ai pas pour toi mais que tu es tu
nages encore un peu d'entre elles sont
encore pas mal tu fais des marathons de
mettre ce mets ton moi j'irai beaucoup
mieux ce stress le que les strees la vie
méthon mais ça ce que tu chantes losc
était en train de faire de coiffer qd tu
je pense que ce qui s'est passé
mettons ces camps dessus tu le sais le
cam qui joue quand tu joues à qui est
lancé qui donne qu'un congé ou en
musique c'est que se met tellement
d'énergie à faire qu'une seule à former
alfort forking bien que peu plus
beaucoup le temps de réfléchir à
d'autres fortes peut pas le temps
mettant de la natation je n'avais pas le
temps de remettre en question ma vision
de la déliquance par le viewty était
tellement rendu dans ta routine ton
corps ici puisque s'envole donc assez
répétitif et radiocor déroutant du salon
pour commencer à réfléchir sur la façon
de réagir devant tel obstacle tu pose
pas de questions tu veux aussi aller
pisser
c'est quand après cinq ans ça s'est fini
le sic et finalement je suis quelqu'un
et pis c'est un travail aussi
ça aussi c'est défini par natation de ta
vie qui s'arrête au rythme défini par
kw/h qui mouawad doit trouver sa mère et
son fils
avez-vous expérimenté avec bagdad rock
vous moi j'ai fait une faute de lsd ma
vie dit sujet à dos c'est que c'était
quoi ton traite d'enfants
c'est ce qu'ils écoutent à la maison
chez votre acompte équipements le ca
fait ça fait longtemps je pensais fait
cinq-six sa jeune amie qui libanais puis
on est allé moi de mon frère de semaine
au liban on arrivé le 31 décembre soit
on restait 2 e semaine puis mon amie et
muse ea mobile mon frère pinault a mis
le 31 août c'est pour la nouvelle année
pour une habitude une tradition au fait
de la cité faites le moi même j'avais 22
rue pie jamais fait jamais fait ce que
j'avais fait dans ma motion j'en fumais
du parc à s'informer de marx dans ma vie
ta petite peluche zino hâte de l'essayer
manhwa note onenote
c'est un gars qui je fais que j'ai
confiance les mâcon vient et étalages
fais pas confiance à ce gala je sais
qu'ici fait ce et fait ses recherches
sur un intellectuel se connaît un
incroyable
je sais que pendant barre c'est ce fake
je te les le repas pour farrell parti
n'en être qu'au long avec le nom
vraiment contrôler parce que c'est un
gars que je connais un stade c'est celui
qui fait ce pour l'expérience psychique
mène quelques sens un petit rituel
spirituel
avec la men arena terres intérieures
lieberman le 31 à 7 heures du soir il
embarque dans un atout romaine puis on
monte puis on roule
puis les libertés se bat la maternité
fait comme la côte puis le beyrouth puis
livre sa cote après ça c'est des
montagnes gros gros haute montagne
encore on roll ça dans un petit chalet
mais dans le fond des montagnes
la plus belle vue que vu ta vie tu vois
toutes les montagnes ses démons en
egypte mais c'est incroyable
l'accord entre la pila qin gang des
libanais mène à minuit on se pose pas
gris cap d'antibes qui est d'assez de
chézard de buzz c'est parti taclé une
heure plus tard c'est le christ qui
quitte une bannière plus tard le chien à
quatre pattes je regarde le tapis mais
je trouve que kate moss tellement
incroyable un petit détail
la pression est là on entre on avait
tout misé on avait toutes les télés
blacklight puis jean les ai faits dans
l'anti-ride semaine on y est on avait
une application sur l'ipad même que
comme tu bouges puis le ça fait comme
une espèce de form factor avec des
couleurs le mot de mon frère andré le
puy ont tiqué sopi petit fils ou petit
fils au pied mais c'est comme si j'avais
compris les forces de soi même comme si
j'avais débloquer quelque chose que
j'avais jamais vu avant plus je le
voyais cette école c'est comme j'étais
en connexion avec l'univers les étoiles
tout les kits mendy ses complices au
sort lui je me disais j'avais la
lucidité de me dire demain
quant à bois doit être fini vous trouvez
que tes réflexions en ce moment
puisqu'ils étaient compris le sens mais
je me disais tout personnage me dit vous
vous trouvez qu'on d'abord eu ses
réflexions le dessus écrit par la cei
qui plongerait les us parce que je me
suis jeune je me suis pas exactement
je me souviens certaines réflexions
certains trucs qui s'est installée diplo
philosophie
religion bien étoiles puis puis je me
disais line 6 voies où tu vas perdre un
petit peu ça mais là à ce moment je me
suis dit si tu as compris c'est l'auto
raisons notamment être pur est ce que je
me disais puis qui a raison je ne sais
pas mais c'était vraiment beau toute la
nuit on est parti marcher dans la
montagne montant jusqu en haut avec la
musique c'est ça va plus je pensais de
stimuli le sens réel ne soit absolument
espace des musiques épiques mais on
monte en montagne même chiche le croyant
le seigneur des anneaux la nature j
j'ai adoré ça pitt et apprécié je pense
que c'est une question de le faire avec
les bonnes personnes
ce long moment à bonne place ici jamin
était jamais mais j'ai vraiment mou
sujet g j'ai commencé à avoir un petit
peu de votre temps en temps philippe
dossmann crossing mois puis d'apprendre
succès quoique ça fait chimique depuis
bloomberg
c'est parce qu'on est tous que tout le
monde nous dit où c'est la société de
nous mais des restrictions sur plaine
afin dans la façon hauban spi et igo ton
ego est vraiment forte et je trouve que
lsd enlève tout ton égo et 10 ans
effectivement puis écouter de la musique
mais je pense tout à écouter de la
musique de ces magnifiques t'attend
toutes les bêtes sont tes même ta vision
sur sa saison pourrait regarder la télé
la date qui est l'hôte pour elle a
regardé pendant une heure puis voire
très léger détail incroyable et mini
affable d'un dans les petites lignes tu
vas en même temps voir l'univers même
pied
c'est comme tout se connectent comme
tout les connecter c'est vraiment fou
quand tu clames end prochain
il ya de la beauté là dedans il ya des
parkings il y avait mon choix quelle
énergie balboa je pense qu'il ya
certaines choses qui qu'il fait pas le
métier de l'énergie ça existe l'énergie
je crois vraiment les mains gym puis
quand on regarde effectivement sur la
liste des du bois ou des marques
c'est comme si toute essence était
décuplée j'ai fait de la mechta de la
méditation sur nous sur les idées des
fois pis
c'est vraiment intense et magique
mais encore une fois c'est faux faux
faux le faire intelligemment
je veux moi c'est puis surtout c'était
citadine au losange était jeune et douée
mais c'est une des dommages que ça a été
mal vu dans les années quoi ce soit 166
que les études parce qu'ils ont fait des
grosses études là tu mènes longtemps
puis ils ont mis comme 8x instigateurs
puis les 800 scientifiques lyon il y
avait il y avait des problèmes que ça
faisait des années qu'ils étaient
capables de régler les problèmes
monsieur scientifique puis 1,7 et avait
tout réglé leur problème
croyant pas parce que deux banderilles
une longue guerre soyouz juste tu avais
pas peur d'essayer des trucs tu avais
pas par dalila dans la pensée avec
talent et et anémone et de newark de
recul tard passerait non pis je pense
que un jour je souhaite vraiment qui on
le voit déjà été on voit avec le chéneau
merouana c'est magnifique ce que ça fait
je trouve que le poids mouche pour
quelqu'un qui fait vraiment du patch une
fois de temps en temps je ça m'amène pas
grand chose en fait la firme demain on
avait ce pouvoir encore celle que c'est
la pire drogue sur la planète avec mes
sacs d'alex je souhaite qu'un jour puis
on le voit avec qu'à la radio machine
generali gan et j'aimerais ça qu'il ya
descente ou que les gens peuvent râler 1
l'as bopp et s'installer sécurité en
sécurité le remède c'est exact déjà
parce que oui parce qu'on est plus bas
que le monde sont entrés dans un peu de
verifone pis ça ferait ça ferait du bien
je pense d'eux ça nous aide à comme
ralentir la vie 30 secondes de process
ah bon chemin et après ce bain temps au
thorax pizzitola mathieu processus
chaque jour chaque semaine chaque mois
60 peu de temps en temps un petit widget
je pense ça serait ça serait vraiment
positif sur sur les gens moi j'avais
déjà lu je sais pas si c'est vrai ou
c'est prouver quoi que ce soit que ces
gens-là de régler ça peut aussi ses
méthodes et blessures de vieilles
blessures d'enfance des choses comme ça
en fuite si ça peu comme t'amener à
dives et à l'explorer ben oui absolument
mais mbia mais risquées comme l'euro
vercoutre et parce que salah et fixing
pitesti fait que le tir il commence à
voir des centres de mdm ou que les gens
dans l'armée qui ont ce problème là où
même les gens normal aussi que dit que
c'est àdire mais ils s'en vont le
français petit à petit je pensais 3 3
12e de mdm appuie les gens vivent des
expériences incroyables je pense et 70%
des gens sort de la retraite et ont pu
pitié sdige ans et 70 60 pour ça
incroyable fou magique en fait zyed ya
du bon côté mais évidemment ce quidam un
sikh
il ya des gens qui abusent c'est ce que
ça peut être dangereux
c'est pas trop trop d'alcool dans l'ue27
en train de trop
les gens abusent de cette affaire
l'obsédant manche c'est vraiment demain
doivent en faire de l'élite faisait du
saumon chômage des jeunes un peu de
moche mais moi je trouve que c'est plus
je trouve que tout est fait est fait
tu vois des affaires qui sont gênés
raisons sont pas réels puis sur la scène
ont l'impression que je trouve que tout
est pas mal réel je sais pas si je peux
faire sur des chemins non c'est ça des
choses je peux voir des affaires que
dans le fond ce existe mais là si je
trouve que tu étais je n'ai pas été
présent si tu bois des belles choses tu
vois pas d affaires qui sont pas
réellement le jeu je peux je m'exprime
bien jeu mais j'ai jugé j'aime pas ce
temps que les tomates c'est tamalous van
damme année parce que c'était une
gestion un pic puis c'est comme tu dis
mais je trouve je trouve pas que sam
amener quelque chose non conscient non
ça m'a pas mais plus britz et plus pas
plus brillant mais ça m'a pas éduquer le
goût
j'aimerais parler justement ex andreck
beaucoup et puis j'aime expérimenter
vraiment les prix du thé au moins une
fois mais j'ai l'impression j'écoutais
world band hier par les dix salariés et
veillées spirituelles noir et puis lui
il fait plus de drogues matin j'ai eu
trop de problèmes à 20 mai mais a buzzé
et abusaient abuser de main mais
maintenant il lui est convaincu qu' il
ya un autre niveau de conscience qu'on
peut atteindre que l'humain va atteindre
un jour qu'on n'a pas atteint encore
puis moi dans tout ce je crois je crois
moi je pense type job je le réussis main
si jobs ans c'est déjà
c'était quoi lui a fait lui a créé toute
la ligne apo / la sinne fait je trouve
que je pense que lui il ya quelque chose
que connectés il ya quelque chose que
moi ce que je pense qu'ils se jouent ce
team et ont quelqu'un qui le monde comme
ceux qui pensent complètement autre sac
de boxe il ya deux enfants pour exprimer
une idée même si la chose en or mais ton
pour faire quelque chose qui est
complètement décalé faut que tu ailles
absolument une vision du monde et
qu'elle soit c'est par crotone côte la
folie maintenant on comprend jean leloup
c'est qui qui est déconnecté de la
réalité
depuis qu'il est tout jeune pittsburgh
fait c'est comme hip hop psychotique le
gisti foule non mais quand même
déconnecté de la société comme on la
connaît maintenant appelons cela société
à place des réalités sauf que des
bougies au dessus jean leloup je trouve
je pense qu'il est allé trop loin dans
certaines affaires possibles évoqués
mais mechmache écoute allons-nous regard
neuf
mais je trouve qu'ils magique mêlant
médard sont sont à noter que tout ce
qu'ils pensent en fait c'est ce qui fait
qu'ils réussissent gueule fait vraiment
ce que lui au goût de farce c'est
vraiment génial mais tu as raison la
résonance pourquoi ce qui a fait est
tellement hors de ce qui avait été fait
avant c'est qu'ils y voient le monde je
suis différent que pour une personne qui
voit pas nécessairement le monde
différemment par une disposition mentale
mais de le voir différemment à travers à
travers la lunette d'une drogue qui
t'amène un autre niveau de conscience
possiblement berné a ainsi à trouver
quelque chose que nos barrières comme tu
dis nous empêche de nous achever bah oui
mais c'est de parler steve jobs spi ont
parlé d' équilibre tantôt s'il huit
génisses indéniable rigueur et steve
jobs stages animés c'est pas un gars qui
atteint l'équilibré dans toutes les
sphères de cette non au sol avec senna
avec sa roue de huawei non je
comprendrais cap seulement 6
on défende admire certaines personnes
mais qui au niveau personnel le niveau
des crottes le train c'est comme tout
pas voir ces gars là comme boss ou comme
père ou comme larry ou comme sauf que
c'est un génie dans les lui ai dit ce
que réellement passionné et il savait
que ça n'allait sur une chose les
responsables avaient voulu grande
dynastie agen-sud netflix qu'est ce que
c'est un gars qui lui fait tout pour
réussir le puits et nude crois qu'ils
ont fait mais c'est une voie qui en haut
du monde qui il rien est important sauf
cette chose cette chose là puis c'est en
fait
bravo pour certains qu'ils font même
année au gala infectés comme mon père je
pense que c'est un peu ce qui a fait
toute sa vie de mimi mimi et c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'il réussit mal voir
dans sa vie il a amené je pense qu'elle
est ici il réaliser qu'ils font gaffe
kit fn puis là c'est le cas qu'ils
réalisaient qui avait tout seul s'il
puis on a parlé un petit peu tendu mais
c'est là que mon père et moi 21 ans
d'une grosse crise de chicanes à maison
c'est là qu'on ne commence à connecter
celles qui comme réaliser que dans le
fond un casting a beau me a gan fucking
kill gamin galeriste d'un manga give
them nage mais tout semaine mettons
qu'on se regarde en tant que l'histoire
de la race humaine c'est si ton père
avait pas été comme ça on serait passé à
côté du meilleur gardien
l'histoire de l'année de chercher je me
disais ouais c'est comme si jobs serait
steve jobs mais il se soucie dommage que
jamais été capable de fable 3 kilowatts
jeune fille puis passer du temps avec ma
famille souvent les great c'est ce qui
marque l'histoire ce petit monde qui
était bel et bien c'est les intenses
avant du monde débarrassé points pour
pau
enfin c'est pas récemment les plus
heureux c'est personnel en fait si on
part la barrière saison mais je pense ça
prend des gens débats lancés pour
pousser les barea ben oui mais oui
donc c'est qui qui nous montrent à
coucher au zoo de bagdad c'est une bonne
question
c'est une bonne question je crois que
c'est tout voir les gens de voir à
l'extérieur les gens tu sais comme du
comme quelqu'un comme si on disait
alphonse jobs un trou de fixer enfin
c'est ça prend du devoir de voir le
contre exemple - très probablement je
sais pas c'est souvent les gens n'agit
pas par contre exemple c'est mon pari
ils mettent sans un pays toujours
travaillé de ses 62 eur quand on était
enfin puis moi je voyais ce que je me
disais je ferai pas si je vais pas de
raison des heures parce que mes enfants
me verront peu parce que ça va être trop
de pression quitte à avoir un salaire
moins élevé ti et souvent on réagit on
agit en contre exemple en fait puis
peut-être que tout le vécu c'est ton
père de jack et moi j'ai juste eu
d'enfance le possiblement que ce pôle
enfance que je donnais mes enfants cela
absolument
même si tu as une enfance heureuse
légèrement question mais peut-être un
jour mais je dis il ya certaines choses
qui effectivement que moi j'ai pas aimé
dont la façon mon parrain gérer ce avec
nous c'est ce que je ferais postés
c'était même erreur le même mon par mu
c'est bon pour mu avait été un homme
fait que cela n'était pas prêt d'avoir
des enfants surtout avec ce qui arrive
est pour lui dans sa vie il n'a gagné la
coupe stanley un autre message aux
générations aussi un corps humain en
génération mais effectivement te je vois
les erreurs que l'on en fait c'est ce
que certaines afin que je serai pop il
ya certaines affaires qui ont fait
qu'ils étaient magnifiques de l'amour
l'amour compte et moi j'ai eu beaucoup
d'amour ce jeu je conscient
qu'aujourd'hui
cindy des qualités que j'ai à love to
give love love dans l'attaqué de sopron
d'après si les gens qui donnait de l'amo
des déluges des plus belles la fac mais
ma famille môme on me donnait vie pour
toi je suppose tc quel genre de relation
avec tes parents tu es tu est ce que
vous êtes si proche avec ma mère oui mon
par pote nécessairement encore
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui se rapprocher un
peu avec le temps je pense depuis en
fait c'est avec le divorce de mes
parents sont moins cons se rapprocher
m'ont valu moins juste parce que là on
prenait des moments pour se parler
seppi puis jetez plus rendu un adulte
donc un enfant fait que la relation
qu'on avait c'était plus un ami qui
devait pas amicale mais c'était plus
quand comme deux amis ensemble que que
comme un porc puis un fils puis des
décalages
2 je pense qu'ils en même temps que sa
volonté non ça c'était 13-14 mon enfant
ça ça fera plus qu'entre 13 14 ans moi
ça pas moi ça me en fait moi ça m'a pas
dérangé le divorce
je trouvais ça comme de deux femmes
qu'il adopte un nouveau c'est du nouveau
puis je voulais vraiment mes parents
soient heureux moi c'est ça aux legs de
big dance mais pas soit heureux
ce test of a man en avant que ça se
passe non non non tu as profité souvenir
oui un peu oui un peu pour certaines
personnes c'est comme une libération way
qui ça fait deux ans qu'on n'est pas
capable puis leurs enfants non mais
écoute ça a été non c'est au 9 mai par
un scanner rare même vraiment c'était on
avait quand même dans l'atmosphère là
vraiment une belle atmosphère la maison
je pense que avec le temps mon père mais
puma et ses carrés je trouve ce affaire
je trouve ce jeu tout ce beau mais que
ça ne c'est correct fine we have told
you accept the surfers faut accepter que
oui si on s'est rencontré le 10 15 20
ans un pee wee chains on évolue même
qu'il faut voir faut arrêter d'être
fâché après les autres qu'ils nous
laissent parce que si on veut que
c'était quelqu'un qui t'aiment pas ne
sais pas ce jeudi à ma mère encore
aujourd'hui même de la chance est avec
quelqu'un qui va vraiment aimé pour
quitter si vous dit quoi tu voudrais
voulu rester pas ta vie puisse avoir
quitté m'bow un style ouais ça pas de
sens sans sa part ça c'est vraiment des
décideurs apprend mais tape ajouté parce
que cette famille des enfants de lydia
large en incluant ces sites
c'est une grosse crise de patin mais ça
a été le meilleur move pour tout le
monde non là ma famille je peux pour
vous autres mais
ça m'a rapproché de même ma femme mon
frère et ma soeur même si on sait j'ai
perdu de vue massa pendant des années
mais on sait comment retrouver après 5,6
à la relation que ma mère m et plus vert
que jamais mon père et moi main qui
s'est rendu - mais mertzen fait que ça
l'est vraiment moussa koussa laisse à
l'oeil dé ma famille mais ça le détruit
en quelques soucis 1 puis surtout quand
il ya de l'argent dans ces cibles au
stick site à flot tu parle pas des
sommes non c'est dommage et c'est
dommage que ça fait tout se passe que
l'hélium évidemment divergent pas je
sais pas trop si ton père t'a manqué
parti commun accord un accord dès demain
du moins c'est mon paquet partie avec
karine inquiétante à bernard von mois
après son marathon bas des pressions
pour un bon plusieurs années et c'est
lots 5 et of peace et je suis c'est
grâce à ma ça c'est encore le moment
parce que moi j'ai moi j'écris ces mots
qu'un sage cgt a pu bien parce qu'à
pleurer a pleuré pleuré après à pleurer
à crier puis tual state of pour elle ça
et puis il n'y avait plus rien que je
pouvais j'avais l'impression que je
pouvais faire
l'ajfer la canine du mouvement puis j'ai
l'impression que tout le monde attend
mouvant pour qu'elle advienne bien sochi
qu'émouvante fait qu'on est comme tout
parti éventuellement henchy aux lofts au
bar sauf et c'est là que je trouve
qu'elle a évolué à l'ats pascal à elle
pour elle c'était ta famille non mais la
caisse est en train de perdre ça fait
rage puisque vous allez me again
thibault situation fait que la lgv est
qu hélas assez découvert découverte
découvrir des couleurs découverte puis
maintenant je la vois est heureuse et
bien alors
participe à mon parent ils m'ont pas plu
plus heureux que jamais aussi ma soirée
a indiqué un petit bébé sont
son son mari fred et c'est plus dans
l'en qui rend dieu endroit à toi j'ai
l'impression que ça l'est vraiment
ouvert tout est juge
ça nous a vraiment fait du bien à tout
le monde c'est bizarre à dire mais ça
nous a fait du bien
des fois tu mènes des fautes 10 plus
l'art plus la relation est long plus des
implications de ces familiale est tous
plus est long avant de sortir du creux
mais quand tu sors du creux
ça vaut la peine c'est quoi deux ans
comparativement aux résultats finaux
c'est exact ça reste deux ans ça reste
le candidat mais c'est chiant mais c'est
quoi comparer de vivre semaine vincent
une ration quitter la ville
partant de là les phases que tu as le
goût même si ta part le muguet je partis
c'est quand je partis la deuxième fois
avec montréal j'avais des bonnes âmes
c'est ma course et le font pas parce que
il voyait que je commence à voyager plus
j'avais plus intérêt à voir le monde qui
jetait - je voulais je le faire plus que
moi j'avais goût femmes musicalement le
jus un appel de jti michael caton moi et
ma peine vient il vous dirait que tu lui
parles de chaud puis j'ai fait une faute
d'aller là-bas mange à la chienne aucune
disent que ce qui pouvait m'arriver je
j'ai fait comme 4,5 audition d'âge en et
j'en ai pas parlé encore la personne
vraiment mais j'ai fait quatre cinq
conditions
puis j'ai fait je comme 3 3 avec des
producteurs au début comme assez
détourne voir ce qui ce qui serait bon
très satisfaite gros show en avançant mn
puis puis toute la gang
c'est pour sa tv
c'était dans le fond ça passe ça
passerait sûrement pas télé mais j'ai
fait des déductions j'ai passé ouais
tout a bien été
j'ai eu je dis oui à part scène et après
ça tu atteins la pression d'attentes
attend un appel de la production pour
savoir si de network va t'amener dans
dans le show puis malheureusement j'ai
eu un appel qui dit oui tu as passé la
deuxième ronde mais le network trouver
d'autres histoires plus intéressante que
la tienne dans ce point guard si tu fais
le même style mais une expérience
incroyable puis c'est ça je te dis ça
fait du bien d'aller dans l'inconfort
puis d'aller chercher des trucs et après
ça que j'ai fait
j'appelais reste où tu lis toutes les
bonnes causes canada pour voir s'ils
voulaient mme signé maji adjusting
d'appui pour dont 19 ont trouvé d'autres
histoires plus intéressante c'est
vraiment histoire aux ongles ses bois et
ses ouailles sommes fous de crème mains
il a fallu là que j'ai l'impression que
j'ai pris un j'ai choisi la mauvaise
stone qui ont choisi la tonne pour moi
mais j'aurais dû faire comme une
organisation milieu du show j'aurais dû
créer un moment des crimes au fait que
j'arrête de change de toupie le jarret
de farine ouais well done and you know
what de gare en gare de base à messi je
n'ai pas fait j'y restais haïti dans nos
bacs
j'ai l'impression de pas avoir eu de
coups et puis même avec toute
l'expérience que j'ai dans ce milieu
j'ai l'impression que ce amour j'aime et
que je t'ai khimar accord jeudi croûte
ancrer sa marge cette rentrée de
danseurs
gmail ou patins euh ouais
oui parce que j'aime ça doit te faire
ouais j'aime pas ça m'a été fait en
amont de l'imaginer je te dirai ça m'a
rien fait c'est pas vrai ça marche ça
mais ça me effectivement vraiment touché
parce que j'ai travailé d'été d'enlever
allauch visite je me réveillais 8h 9h le
matin puis je jouais de la musique
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin dans le
stockage y investit énormément d'un fake
quand dessus tu as l'impression que tu
restes tu as fait tout ça pour rien avec
ses succès comme fac mais en vérité ce
que tu réalises c'est que ça te pousse
et élimine c'est ça je veux moi j'adore
pousser mes limites pour ce que je pense
c'est moi j'ai aucun talent la musique
l'idée c'est un message pour tout le
monde on n'est pas moche pas talentueux
elle travaille cadastre déjà vu aux
catalans à 19 mi-temps 15-13 je commence
à écrire très changeante et
charles-edouard douche puis jetée pause
je t'ai pas bon même à 19 ans je suis
prof durham puis cgg c'était nul à chier
bain mais j'avais un désir de réussir
j'avais un but fait quand ça après sa
belle fille tu te donnes même puis tu
vas chercher les outils nécessaires pour
atteindre ton temps tombent ultime et
c'est ça ma force
en fait cessé de de pommes à cidre bio
maison farine semaine je je dis que tout
le monde est capable de faire ce qu'ils
aiment vraiment je le crois vraiment on
est intelligent on y brise mais on est
vraiment intelligent mais c'est de se
donner la chance de le faire et de faire
les sacrifices pour dhafra les
sacrifices pour moi oui je pense que
c'est ma soeur qui est ce encore une
fois
ton bonheur faut que tu ailles chercher
y arriverai pas' s'était assis puis tu
fais rien faut que tu saches que tu le
trouves première main faut que tu le
prennes pillay est à toi
ouais mais il va pas arriver si tu fais
rien fait non si tu fais juste enlever
les matins à la même heure faire la même
chose
constamment ça peut être un peu trop
heureux mais c'était pas heureux dans ce
le bon on va pas arriver tout seul ce
qui est grave c'est que l'état du genre
de trop se poser de questions puis vit
sa petite vie que l'on attend toujours
de stabilité qui nie du bonheur ni du
malheur public en tentant de la route de
se trouver vraiment peut descendre un
crédit parce que tu peux te poser toutes
les questions du monde
puis c'est tout les barbies le sicom
crèches des écoles
ces mouches pas je pense pas qu était le
thème être l'idiot dû village est
heureux où je pas trop le thé celui où
celui qui se pose pas de question 5e
seul écart et oui tout à fait c'est
correct sauf que là toi post le way mais
le chemin mêle soul kitchen qu'il faut
faire pour finalement se retrouver
piètre rumine stansted routes sinueuses
et dur qui peut toujours le fun mais ces
mesures le 10 qui magnifie calbet week
s'est magnifiquement grecs doivent y est
plus confiant parce que t'es peut-être
réussi quelque chose a investi du temps
d'un kant est rendu à fin tu réalises
que tu es pas fin des jeux ouais mais
dans la vie king kong attaque la ligne
en fait c'est qu'un combat mais avant ce
qui amène la cour est ce une patente
mais avec des revues comme si ce qu'on
m'a dit on la contrôle toi c'est pas ça
s'est passé de la culmination mathieu
c'est pour ce genre de moment fort cette
sentence et s'est fait toute la course
avant pis si quelques courses le fait
même d'être fait une belle course était
une bonne courte tête était bon de
traiter un tout fait de quoi faire la
meilleure course que l'accord sytral
plusieurs rugbymen et m
c'est qu'un qu'on écoute chez moi le 29
juillet ça va ça va sortir un premier
single c'est quoi c'est un premier
senghor qui que j'ai fait à aller avec
les boys ça fait que ça fait l'icis a
fait un ipad et un vidéo pour cet
honneur je vois fils mais de quoi
d'après moi début ou la latinva sortir
juger mon équipe fait que la tour nord
sortie on va tuer la tuna radio la
presse on va voir ce que ça va donner
et offrir la réponse doit être bonne à
travers le canada à travers le québec
puis après ce bain le vidéo je veux
sortir en nous mais ça va être plus un
genre de live live acoustique vidéo un
peu comme je pense que vu le vidéo de
moi que renshaw magnifique comment c'est
fait je veux je veux je me sauve voir
les gens chanter blige pour smasher
double allégeance chabot diète vidéoclip
maintenant même si j'adore faire des
vies au clip je pense que j'aime plus
fade et live christique veilleuse il
tente on video games in them the border
line cet été ça a été tout sauf à faire
parce que je suis allé dans des dindes
et amanda d'examen d'entrée mamère moins
je suis allé dans les plus diplômés
pires moments de ma vie en fait le puits
c'est les scènes de douche avec avec moi
qui pleurent dans douche nullos tester
ce test est vilain petit tout le monde
avait du monde on était peut-être 40 qui
est en elle tous voient même écart
antérieures de la caméra et puis tout le
monde nous avait du monde qui peut lui
qui hallucine et de ce qui se passe
était c'était évident tout le monde
parce que pour moi la douche est
l'endroit où que ses loques tout sort je
sais pas pourquoi le moins de douze
maintenant à douche mandy je bois je
peux braille et ça m'a fait drôle on a
fini avec lou qui me tombe dessus je
sais pas si c'est paisible
ouais ça me chan kam python de toutes
les émotions peut sortir ça fait du bien
fait que j'avais je pense que j'ai
connecté jeux vidéo ou la connecter que
les gens sachent tout l'alcool sig
l'ijtihad danemark hellphone nos pieds
métier j'ai l'impression que même si
c'est cela qui me fait connaître partout
au canada
c'est pas celle là que j'aurais voulu
que les gens connaissent dessus parce
que même moi je chante pis je sais pas
moi
ouais mais je comprends pas pourquoi ce
tic à la marche au tabarnak mec les
salles de marché puis deux tings pour
moi le support aux ide a wish
puis elle a quand même pensé que huit
cent mille cent mille views altia à
l'heure où les la libye
j'aurais voulu kagan quelque chose au
doux nom je trouve que a mérité de
gagner quelques méritait de gagner
quelque chose de vidéo le jeu des sud
pour avoir gagné quoi parce qu'on ne
sait où on a envoyé une onde le missouri
comment t'appelles ce
sans voix c'est quoi le gpat ab nantais
se met à tourner ce matin à 12 puis on
n'a pas eu de réponse puis j'étais déçu
main parce que affaire aux abris à vélos
sur la dépression puis la réalité de ce
qu'on ce que beaucoup de gens comme ça
connecter avec la banque puisse à
connecter parce que c'est vrai et puis
c'est toi tu sais c'est toujours semaine
moi je pense que c'est toujours cela
clymène le plus vrai le plus le plus tôt
possible
qu'est ce qui t'a marqué de plus de
cette vidéo le toit basse ex mtc des
façades de toi conte que vous connaissez
pour le monde connaissait pour un thé
puissance allemande scott pour s'exposer
demain sauf que tu fais ça fait crise
quelques hits mangue
tc j'ai eu beaucoup de reproches pour
dire que si il veut que le suicide à la
fête
et puis puis le monde est comme si bon
de montrer ça aux jeunes mais la réalité
mouche des contacts le monde soit en
crise dessus parce que ça la rive et les
jeunes les jeunes aujourd'hui on la
difficulté de vivre avec leurs émotions
pis il y en a beaucoup qui kiffent
qu'ils font et moi je voulais comme
partir la discussion ait quelqu'un va
pas bien ce point tandis que celle de ne
pas être là pour elle ou lui c'est un
2-2 aider les gens de d'aider la
personne qui est m puissent nos amis
nous nos familles je trouve c'était seul
point du vidéo a surtout à la fin des
fonds dans l'impression et vas y que rec
les cendres iql c'est mon meilleur chum
puis ça ne vit qu'à un moment vraiment
dissidence à vue qui tombe en dépression
puis asti jeune j'avais aucune idée même
pu me le disait oh ouais mais il me le
disait d'une façon de jeter quand même
standard et l'institut
sors de ta bulle noter qu'avec des
quarts et puis finalement était pas
correct pis ça m'a affecté que ça
m'affecte encore aujourd'hui de ne pas
avoir su taverne qui allait pas bien et
je trouve que c'est important de
s'instruire de comprendre qu'est ce
qu'on fait
comment comment on peut aider quelqu'un
si certains concepts ne fait pas dire et
rien dire ça fait le point non mais
vraiment pas qu'est ce que tu fais c'est
quoi les les quotas c'est à dire
certaines affaires concis mais là et
puis je crois
puis je crois pas que c'est de la m je
crois pas que c'est de la médication
il ya beaucoup de monde qui vend du bac
s et chimiques mal à ma cervelle piteux
état mais encore une fois le document
jose que je vais t'envoyer tu va
l'écouter tout va capoter son baleineau
le jeu créatif en texte
malaysian amis je crois que la
médication c'est juste un fait qu'une
place tort je revends maxter placer un
petit plastoc du mepi le bomb ou encore
parce que évidemment
ouais mais est ce une once de preuve et
son aide
je ne sais pas encore cammas soigner ou
aider les gens 400 m
sans la médication de gamme amaral ses
droits parce que elle est arrêtée sur la
médication puis mais na li pue ça a pris
du temps
pis je crois que je crois jusqu'à la
médication peut-être aidé à calmer
pensez à what the fuck et parce que j'ai
l'impression que la police n'a bien son
nom c'est nadine morano
merci beaucoup mais les premiers pas de
casse de ma vie j adore et ce à la
demande de gaz je regrette mais vous
complétez vraiment bien même si le fun
pis il ya une belle vague vous avez créé
vous êtes vraiment trippant puis je vous
souhaite énormément de succès si je
souhaite de revenir déprécie vraiment
bas je peux pour toi mais moi je trouve
qu'il s'est passé spécial dans ce
podcast vraiment rock au volant d'un
personnel en fait on on sait jamais
vraiment janvier toutefois en personne
je pense avoir on a des amis en commun
bon le jeu mais on n'a jamais pris le
temps de deux genres de tupi goethe
attirer aussi var var toit de cette côte
et le mental de les choses que je vois
tu aimes servi la même chose avec toi je
vois que vous amis les mêmes choses que
moi je trouve ça débile que vous voulez
apprendre sur pleine crise de pas
tendres ou seule femme ça vient me
chercher challans poule main mais si
bien qu une production du studio sfr est
merci d'avoir été là j'espère que vous
avez aimé les podcasts on remercie
ashley ferait kitna bonne et pétillante
qui a pris le forfait charlotte donc on
le dit en gros un beau gros merci qui
merci d'encourager puis à lecce qui sont
contenus dans le fond a fait des vidéos
sur youtube et sur instagram alors h les
forêts merci beaucoup
yes puis si vous voulez vous aussi avoir
un chat l'art de diriger vers une autre
page pétulante pour plus d'informations
sur ce see you next 1